الأخبار العاجلة كشف قاضٍ في فلوريدا للتو
عن قائمة جرد كاملة أكثر تفصيلاً
لجميع المستندات التي تم تصنيف العديد منها
مأخوذ من منزل ترامب في فلوريدا
Mar-A-Lago في هذا البحث في
الثامن من أغسطس ، لدينا هنا ولدينا
فريق كان يبحث  من خلاله ،
والحكم على بعض الأهمية هنا ،
كارا أنت وأنا أثناء استعراضنا لهذا
المخزون الطويل ، يتخطى 33 عنصرًا في
ثماني صفحات ، شيء واحد ملحوظ هو
مجرد المعاملة أو أفترض أنه يمكنك قول
سوء المعاملة وأن هذه
المستندات شديدة الحساسية قد تم إلقاؤها في
صناديق حاويات أجزاء من
مكتب الرئيس مع أشياء أخرى.
المجلات كتب الملابس والهدايا نعم
أعني أنك ترى أنها ليست مجرد واحدة من
هذه الصناديق والحاويات الموصوفة
هنا وهي قائمة من
33 أو نحو ذلك منها نعم ثلاثة صناديق
وحاويات جديدة أعني  ترى في
إحداها في مجلاتها مقالات صحفية ثم
11 وثيقة سرية وثيقة سرية
21 مع علامات تصنيف سرية
ثم مواد تجلط.  hing
and Gifts كتابًا ثم
سجلات حكومية أخرى غير مصنفة حتى
تشعر نوعًا ما بأن هذا
عشوائي جدًا ، فليس هذه
المستندات السرية للغاية لا يتم
الاحتفاظ بها بالطريقة الآمنة
التي يُطلب منها أن تكون  تم ذلك ،
وهذا يوضح لك مدى اتساع
ما يجب أن يكونوا قد عثروا عليه عندما ذهبوا إلى
هناك ونظروا إلى هذا
المكان الذي تعلمون أننا نراه أيضًا وهناك ما
تم ختمه أيضًا اليوم كان
تقرير حالة فريق التحقيق وفي
ذلك المدعون العامون  اكتب أنك تعرف
أثناء مرورهم
بمواد البحار أن أحد الأشياء التي
يبحثون عنها ليس فقط
المستندات نفسها ولكن طبيعة
وطريقة تخزينها
وقالوا إن ذلك سيبلغ
تحقيق الحكومة  وإخباره
أنه يقول أيضًا مقابلات مع الشهود
وممارسات هيئة المحلفين الكبرى ، لذلك من المؤكد أنه
لا يزال استثمارًا نشطًا للغاية أعني
أنه يسلط الضوء على النقطة التي لا تتعلق
فقط بالاحتفاظ بهذه  المستندات
التي تخص الحكومة
لا تخص الشخص ولكن أيضًا كيف تم
تخزينها خلال تلك الفترة الزمنية
بالمناسبة إذا حصلت على تصريح أمني ،
يتم حفرها في رأسك لمعالجة
المستندات بعناية بسبب
خطر خروجها  Evan Perez كما
لاحظنا هنا المجلدات الفارغة المدرجة في هذا
المخزون وكذلك
نعم Jim وانظر كنت أنظر إليها على
سبيل المثال ، أنت تعرف أن حاوية صندوق من
غرفة التخزين مُصنَّفة على أنها في البند 18
وأن هذين المجلدين الفارغين المسمى
بالعودة إلى سكرتير الموظفين العسكري  المساعدة
هناك الكثير من الأشياء التي تعرفها والتي
لا يمكننا استخلاص أي استنتاجات
واضحة ولكن هل تعلم أنها تتناسب
مع نمط ما نعرفه
عن ممارسات الرئيس السابق عندما كان
رئيسًا وهذا هو نوع الشيء
الذي  هيئة المحلفين الكبرى أن أي
شهود سيقدمون أمام
هيئة المحلفين الكبرى للتحقيق في هذه القضية أه هذه
كجزء من هذا
التحقيق سوف يُسألون عن
قضية الرئيس.  يصرح أنك تعرف أن
أحد الأشياء التي نعرفها هو أنك تعرف أنه كان
معتادًا عليه عندما كان يتلقى إحاطة
أنه سيطلب المستندات
ويرغب في الاحتفاظ بها على الرغم من أن
البروتوكول سيكون عليه إعادتها
إلى أه إلى  المساعدة التي تتعامل
معها وبالطبع تم تسجيل
الدخول إلى هذه الأشياء وتسجيل الخروج منها ، كان
هناك إجراء كامل يتم استخدامه
لتتبع هذه المستندات
وهذا هو سبب وجود الكثير من القلق
داخل مجتمع الاستخبارات بشأن
المستندات المهمة  من الواضح أنهم
يحتفظون بإحكام شديد للغاية
ويتعقبون ما تعلمون أنه سينتهي به الأمر في
البيت الأبيض ثم يختفي نوعًا ما
، كما تعلمون ، ولذا فإن هذا النوع من الملاءمة مع
هذا النمط وأنا متأكد من
أنه سيتم سؤال الشهود عن  أنه عندما
يذهبون أمام هيئة المحلفين الكبرى